I am knuckle buying beast hunter I
hereby challenged the to extermination
team candidates to a duel midnight
tonight sharp fight me fair and square I
won't run away or hide and have no
weapons but I have the courage to face
you do you hello and welcome to Hunter
hunter 101 series that breaks down
everyone and everything in the Hunter
hunter world and today it is time to
examine the hot-blooded beast hunter
knuckle bine knuckle is a youthful and
highly energetic hunter sporting a
trademark pompadour who was first
introduced during the Chimera ant arc
due to his I'll show it for this overly
active lifestyle as well as the fact
that he adopts the retro delinquent
aesthetic the most immediate experience
of knuckle to most people can be summed
up in a single word which is aggressive
in fact for example in the Chimera ant
melee are on first encountered knuckle
he immediately observed that he had a
very hostile face not a hostile aura
just the face as if he was ready to
fight at any moment and that's not
entirely an inaccurate assessment as
knuckle is always willing to jump into
the fray but not in the typical
troublemaker fashion that may be
expected upon first impression instead
my knuckle engages in combat it is
almost always for good and an often
selfless reason to illustrate the
earliest known information we have
regarding knuckle was a situation
proving just this as on the day knuckle
graduated from elementary school
he ended up punching a police officer
which seemed like a classic juvenile
thing to do but as it turns out he only
did so in order to help a friend of his
escape incurring the wrath of the police
in the process in going on to spend all
day and all night evading for patrol
cars but knuckle was never caught in any
case as initially hostile as knuckle
seems a far better word to describe his
persona would be compassionate knuckle
is driven by a profound sense of well
fairness if he sees those in need he
will not hesitate to immediately put his
all into helping them and that doesn't
just go for individuals in dire
situations but seemingly any aspect that
results in the maintenance of a peaceful
society such as cleaning up after dogs
whose owners have neglected to do so
themselves all in a very aggressive
manner I might add it deep down knuckle
is probably one of the most generous and
charitable people in the entire Hunter
hunter world and this disposition also
applies to knuckles enemies as well as
demonstrated Minako admitted that his
reason for wanting to join the Chimera
extermination team was not for the
intent of simply killing the ants but to
actually prevent the systematic
extermination of them but to be clear it
was not that he was opposed to the
deaths of the ants who were threatening
humanity as we know it but knuckle did
not want to engage in such an act
without first facing them head-on
and achieving a form of understanding
which is an incredibly mature viewpoint
coming from such an outwardly juvenile
character although it is something that
he is often chastised from from his
master moral bearing that knuckles
compassionate side is a detriment to
both he and his peers unfortunately very
little is known about how knuckle came
to be morals apprentice or even how
knuckle came to be a hunter in general
although he has said himself that the
circumstances under which he became a
beast hunter is a long story and not at
all a happy one but at some stage during
his career Knuckles master morale was
tapped by Isaac Metro the chairman of
the hunter Association to accompany him
on a mission to exterminate the chimera
ants and an endeavor in which Nicole
vehemently insisted on joining whoever
due to the nature of the mission and
Knuckles disposition towards the kind of
things in life a test was required
before he would be allowed to accompany
the extermination team for this knuckle
was paired up with shoot another
apprentice of morale and they were
picked in combat against gone and
Kilowog who also wished to accompany the
team in order to save Dawn's father's
apprentice kite in the space of a single
month one team had to acquire two
missing hands of a shogi tile held by
the other as proof of their victory and
well knuckle being knuckle he wasn't all
that keen for the tickets so approach
and so he immediately paraded through
the town with a megaphone directly
challenging gone and kilowatt to face
off against him at midnight one thing
here neglected though was to mention the
location of their proposed battle and so
oddly enough : and Kilwa did not show up
that evening ten days later though the
two appeared before knuckle completely
exhausted from the training with Biscay
to which naka verbally chided them and
accused them of not taking this
seriously although his trademark
emotions activated once more as he
teared up at the sheer determination of
the boys and even offered to let them
hit him until they were satisfied but to
forfeit the shogi tiles if they failed
to make him budge from his spot as it
turns out this was a bad idea has gone
began to power up a mighty attack the
unexpectedness of which sent knuckle
into a mild sense of terror racing
through the anticipated possibilities in
his mind causing him to faint
now core proceeded to wake up in the
care of gone and kill WA and after
bonding with them he offered to let them
face him as many times as they wished
within the remaining twenty days and
night after night after training with
Biscay they would seek him out and
after night they would lose also night
after night knuckle seemed to acquire
more and more stray dogs that he began
feeding because he's a good guy
however it would not be until the final
night that knuckle would showcase his
true abilities in regards to nan
knuckles natural affinity is in the art
of omission and his signature hatsue is
known as Hakka soiree and in English has
been translated as bankruptcy chapter 7
the heaven doesn't know my suffering and
just bear with me for a bit because this
has quite a strong technical explanation
to it with this hot su knuckle emits an
indestructible and extremely adorable
mascot known as a PR which stands for
amortizing power redirector a PR can
then be attached to an opponent
immediately after having been dealt a
blow by knuckle and the aura from said
attack is then loaned to the opponent
via a PR now this does result in the
opponent gaining an aura boost courtesy
of knuckle however it does come at a
cost as the opponent becomes unable to
physically damage knuckle until the or
is paid back towards this end any
attacks dealt against knuckle go towards
repaying the aura debt but it is no
simple task to repay that debt has every
10 seconds APR says cheek on this
meaning it's time and adds 10 percent
interest to the previous amount required
to pay knuckle back so with that in mind
things can get out of hand very very
quickly and should the aura debt
calculated by APR surpass the total
amount of aura possessed by an opponent
well then they go bankrupt at this stage
APR 20 2014 2 so it is a potentially
devastating katsu although it does come
with some immediate drawbacks the
primary one being that knuckle has also
rendered unable to inflict any damage on
the opponent as more hits result in him
lending more aura so it forces a kind of
stalemate between equal or lesser
opponents who are unable to swiftly pay
back the aura loaned and this may seem
quite at odds with knuckle style of
fighting which was generally portrayed
as something of a bra however this
hatsue actually perfectly suits knuckles
more peaceful in a lifestyle
taking away the concept of physical
damage and turning the contest into a
bureaucratic game of aura tennis and it
also does work quite nicely with his
previously established ability to outrun
most opponents thus allowing hak awara
to do its thing in isolation and one of
those opponents would be gone who was
unable to overcome the challenge of hot
Kawara and would swiftly go bankrupt as
a result knuckle and she proceeded to
join the extermination team which would
culminate in the nation of east quarter
with a
mara and king marijuana had commandeered
himself a royal palace during the
invasion of the palace knuckles primary
role was to team up with shoot and Mail
Iran in order to eliminate up1 of the
king's royal guards after striking and
equipping a PR - you be now Co then
estimated his aura to be an absurd
700,000 units which was 10 times more
than his master morale an uncle had a
fairly rough roll during this time as
after equipping a PR knuckles job was to
essentially hang back he didn't buy
millions God's accomplice ability and to
allow a PR to run its course and
eventually send you P bankrupt however
this would lead shoot to face off
against the world guard alone and while
he performed admirably and arguably
better than he has in his entire life he
was no match for you P sending knuckle
into tears as he was forced to watch his
friend potentially fight to his death
but once again knuckle being knuckle
there came a point where he could no
longer stand by and he abandoned his
plan making his presence known to you P
thus saving Schutz life in regards to
the ever terrifying you P however nook
who would eventually team up with his
master in order to take him on an
attempt to continue to buy time and
force him to go bankrupt although this
would once again result in knuckle
abandoning the plan when Mara was
gravely wounded by the world guard
knuckle would then strike a bargain with
you Pete despair morals life in exchange
for deactivating a PR this is despite
the fact that you peacetime had been
running out and he would have gone
bankrupt in exactly three minutes and 50
seconds rendering him effectively
defeated for the remainder of the palace
invasion so knuckles decision would have
seemed like madness to anyone else
including Morel who was more than
willing to sacrifice his life for the
sake of the mission furthermore there
was absolutely nothing to stop you P
from breaking their deal and proceeding
to murder Morel anyway but in this
moment knuckle saw something in the
Chimera ant claiming that he wasn't a
bad guy at all and finally that he could
no longer see you P as a being to be
exterminated and Knuckles intuition
proved correct as you piece paired them
all and immediately fled to assist the
king and while knuckle did still
continue to proceed with the palace
invasion he would eventually be knocked
up by maro m and remain unconscious for
the remainder of the event following the
invasion knuckle is one of many people
who volunteered to guard a gravely
injured gun in hospital in order for
killer to heal him using the powers of a
laka into this day knuckle remains good
friends with both of them some more fun
facts about knuckle as a result of his
huckleberry ability knuckle has become
extraordinarily perceptive in being able
to convert aura into measurable
units and is able to very accurately
assess the capabilities and reserves of
an opponent after the palace invasion
knuckles master Morrow was considered as
a candidate to receive a promotion to a
triple star hunter which means that
knuckle himself may even become a single
star hunter as one of the criteria to
advance to a two or three star hunter is
to have a disciple who has received a
single star the acronym APR is actually
based on the term annual percentage rate
which is interest expressed as an annual
rate yeah that's right a bit you weren't
expecting to delve into the world of
Finance when you clicked on this video
but it doesn't stop there as a PR
transform state IRS is a reference to
the Internal Revenue Services Agency
within the United States according to
the limitations of hissatsu knuckle must
be within a certain distance of his
target for APR to continue accruing
interest however that distance required
is subject to inconsistency as it was
originally stated to be 100 metres but
later changed to 50 metres this would
prove relevant when knuckle used taka
whare on g2 who ran far enough away to
deactivate its effects although it did
bring up another nice handy use of Apr
which is that once it is equipped to a
target knuckle is then able to track
that individual and finally a truly
useless fact despite the official viz
translation of knuckles hasu as
bankruptcy chapter 7 it was once for
some reason translated as hak awara
chapter 11 and to be fair chapter 11 is
a real type of bankruptcy but it was
indeed a mistranslation and went on to
potentially suggest that the hearts who
had further variations which it did not
but that pretty much does it for knuckle
if you enjoyed this video and the
content this channel produced in general
then please do consider donating to the
New World review patreon because the
support of all of you amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video
will like share or subscribe because it
also helps support the channel an
incredible amount and if you'd like to
join the fun at any time then please do
head over to my discourse server where a
wide array of shenanigan read takes
place on a daily basis and finally
please do comment with who what or where
you'd like to see featured on the next
hunter hunter one